Weekend I went
and I went up in a helicopter
and today I came and left by helicopter and I will continue.
The times I go
I'm going to go in the helicopter,
I understand you
to the Colombian elite or not.
I am the vice president of this country.
You know me
if at the last minute he decides to go out with a passenger
common,
here it is growing.
Here it is armed.
Here it is structured
in such a way that it can come out.
Well, what's it all about?
He is coming in Moscow,
on a regular flight.
Why?
And because he did not want to travel on AR 0 1
an airplane cost me 25 million,
that people are more used to tango 0 1,
but tango 0-1 was delivered as part of the payment,
huh? Hey,
three million dollars in total would be 25,
paid 22!
Argentina not so long ago,
but it is losing a lot of money.
It is calculated
that three million dollars per semester
just do not use it here.
Was it from breakfast
who went to the tourist class
and said how about
and this happened?